Most people think of ancient Egypt when they picture a mummy,...
...but actually they weren't the only people to make them.
The spirit cave mummies found near Fallon, Nevada, in 1940...
...were mummified more than 9,400 years ago.
Before that, the oldest known mummy on earth still wasn't Egyptian.
It was a child found in Chile and was from around 7,000 years ago.
But it was only about 5,000 years ago...
...that Egyptians started intentionally mummifying the dead.
Part of the reason that Egyptian mummies are so much more well-known...
...is because archeologists have dug up a ton of them.
That's helped experts learn a lot of info about them,...
...including the five basic steps for making a mummy the Egyptian way.
They started by washing the body with wine and water from the Nile River.
Then they removed the organs.
Next, they cleaned the lungs, liver, stomachs and intestines...
...and put them in special pots called canopic jars...
...that are each shaped like an Egyptian god.
The heart was considered the center of intelligence,...
...so it was put back in the body.
After that, they would bury the body completely...
...in a special salt called natron for 40 days...
...to get rid of all the moisture.
Once the body was dry, they would take it out of the salt...
....and fill it with rags, spices and plants to keep its shape.
Finally, they would wrap it up in those famous linen fabric strips.